[Inaudible].
Element 113 is the only one that I've discussed with an
ambassador. In fact,
it's the only one I've discussed with two ambassadors because I've discussed it
with both the old and the new Japanese ambassador to London.
And the reason why I was discussing is because element 113
is the first element to be definitely synthesized in
Japan. And so it is a huge excitement in the country.
I was in Tokyo in February this year, 2016,
and I met a representative of Riken the lab
where these elements were synthesized and they gave me
a press release about the element.
The really exciting thing from their point of view is that they get to choose
the name of this element.
Now you have to understand that making the so-called super heavy
elements is not a quick process.
It's not like boiling things up in a test tube and finding a new
element. It takes years and years and years,
and over the history of the search for elements.
The last 200 years,
there have been hundreds of claims by people believing that they have
discovered new elements.
So now the process is extremely rigorous and now they've got to the
final stage and the name has been chosen.
The name they chose with Niho Niamh,
which is a Latinized version of the Japanese name
for Japan Nihon. I'm sorry.
I pronounced that incorrectly.
The experiments that led to this discovery began
a long time ago, more than 12 years ago,
and like all elements of this part of the periodic table they're made
by taking a heavy element in this case,
bismuth atomic number 83 and the light elements,
this case zinc accelerating the zinc two huge speed
and the nuclei fuse together to make an
element of 113.
What you have to realize is that you take billions
and billions and perhaps trillions of zinc,
atoms to get one atom of element
113.
Apparently the Japanese lab observed three
atoms over a period of nine years.
So this is not something that you do quickly on the Friday afternoon and
publish the next day.
A huge amount of verification is needed to make sure
that what you see is genuine.
And the way that you detect these elements is that
once they formed,
they shoot up to the back of the bismuth target onto a detector.
And then they decay radioactively into a chain of different elements.
And this chain of elements tells you which element you
formed because soon you get to parts of the periodic table where you know,
how the elements decay. What is amazing though,
is that people can also tell a little bit about the chemistry of
these elements.
You can only do a limited amount of chemistry when you have one atom at a time,
but what they can do is to bounce the element,
the atom,
when it's subjected off some sort of surface say gold or
Teflon and see if there is any difference between the way they
stick.
You can tell quite a bit about the elements just from the sticking.
And in fact,
the measurements have been made and element 113 does stick to
gold. Quite strongly.
This part of the periodic table is really unusual because just
by chance,
the way the atomic numbers add up the number of the elements
113 is the same as the group it's in,
or at least the 13 is it's in group 13,
the same element as boron.
And if you go down element 113,
the holmium is just below thallium.
And we know quite a lot about the chemistry of thallium,
particularly it's very poisonous.
Now you can't tell whether the [inaudible] will be poisonous because you only
have one atom. Even if you could get one atom inside somebody,
it would not poison them chemically though.
It's radioactive decay could cause damage.
One of the things that's really interesting about thallium is that it has three
electrons in its outer shell and in its chemistry,
it can lose either one of these to make the Italian plus souls,
or it can lose all three.
And I suspect that in the chemistry of element,
113,
the plus one state would be even more prominent than in the
chemistry of thallium.
Because if you go up the periodic table in the same group to Allie minium,
you don't get aluminum. Plus at all, pneumonia is in the same group.
So it has three outer electrons in just the same way as stallion,
assuming that the electrons are arranged in the same configuration,
because when you get to these large atoms,
the energy levels of the different cells are very close together.
So it would be possible in least in theory for the configuration to be
different.
But people assume that it will be three electrons arranged in the same
way as in boron, but much larger shelf.
The difficulty is that as the atoms get bigger, um,
if you imagine the electron like a particle,
they have to go round and round in the shell and the speeds they're going
round approach the speed of light,
and therefore they mass changes and you get so-called relativistic effects.
We made the video about this on the properties of mercury,
which is a much lighter elements than element and in 13.
So people will have to do quite a lot of calculations.
And in the end, unfortunately,
this will just be theory because it will be very difficult to verify them. Now,
the important question that people always ask is what in earth is the point of
making elements like this?
And the answer is that it gives us a much better understanding of how the
protons and the neutrons in the nucleus bind together.
And it's only when you look at the extremes when they are binding together,
relatively weakly, that you can test whether your theories are any good.
So although it's an enormously expensive experiment,
the results are really very useful.
Professor, do we not already know enough about how protons and neutrons work?
I mean, we can make an atom bombs and nuclear energy.
We understand that everyday elements very well. Why do we need to know more?
Have we not? We're not sort of got our head around it enough.
The radium nucleus threw off an alpha particle consisting of two protons
and two neutron.
The importance of these experiments is that there have been predictions
that when you get very heavy elements,
the so-called super heavy elements,
they may become more stable than one might expect in
general, what has been found as people who've gone up to high,
heavier and heavier nuclei, they've become less and less stable.
But now there is some indication that these very heavy elements are more
stable than one might expect. That doesn't mean they're very stable.
They may only last a small fraction of a second,
but that's longer than people might have expected just by extrapolating the
lifetimes of the other ones. I think it's a great honor to anybody,
to any country.
And I think it is a very nice example of collaboration between
different countries, because although it was discovered in Japan,
its existence was verified and justified by experiments in
Germany and Russia. So it's a very good example of international collaboration.
I find the name slightly difficult to pronounce,
but it's a lot better than [inaudible]
, which I find almost impossible to pronounce. This is the press release. And on the back is a photo of the leader of the team professor
Merita with presumably the periodic table showing elements
. But the thing I really like is the quotation at the end, it says for Merita, then part of the coming year will be devoted to thinking of and proposing a formal name. They've now done that, but he's looking forward to the next step in his research. We plan now to look to the uncharted territory of element 119 and beyond aiming to examine the chemical properties of the elements in the seventh and eight through
of
the periodic table and someday to discover the Island of stability. So all being well, there'll be lots more periodic videos on the subject. Oh, I'm wearing a Japanese happy, which was given to me in Tokyo by a great fan nugget. Yes. So Noah and you can see unfortunately, element 113 comes here in my
arm pit. It's a really nice periodic table and it's even better on the bank.
Hello. And then see where the arms go
by the time we get to here. Yeah.
It's already traveling 5% of the speed of light.
So Target's here and Savine rotates is about 1005
valuations per minute.